is there any advice you would give to
your younger self you know you had to
really turn your life around when you
were 40. if you could go back maybe when
you were 20 or even when you were a kid
what would you say to Sure uh oh man I
could go for it
stop drinking yeah yeah put the bottle
down that would be number one yeah the
other thing would be simply put to Live
Lean like to just keep your overhead as
low as possible and to take whatever
resources you have and invest them in
experience I think your 20s are for
going out into the world and learning
the idea that we're supposed to have it
all figured out and know what we want to
be and do at that age is preposterous
and I think the most interesting people
of all the 700 and whatever you know
they all took a different path they all
like had a sense of believing in
themselves they could pursue the world
like Kevin Kelly like do